kim kardashian just posted your song
which is uh
seems like you know a pretty big deal
yeah it's crazy that she [ __ ] me up i
was on my email when i seen that too
was she uh like
did you have any heads up that was going
to happen
that [ __ ] just happened i seen somebody
tell me in the comments i clicked that
[ __ ] mind you she took her real off of
her page like you could do remove from
me
from your profile but it's still on
there right you're still on it's just
not on but i'm like i'm like i'm i'm
looking on my page like yo that [ __ ]
fake but then i clicked the rail like no
that [ __ ] up there like people tagging
y'all in that show i'm like damn that's
crazy it was the first day i dropped
cupid with the audio
that's crazy yeah bro i straight [ __ ]
that [ __ ] the dirt and he like yo that
[ __ ] happy that's hard
did uh
like did you notice like a spike like
right away or i mean it was the first
day it dropped so you really didn't
really tell the difference the
difference right my [ __ ] been spiking
though like yesterday the day before my
monthlies and all that what do i just
like did you get a bunch of followers on
ig after she posted it no
no
she ain't tagged me in it but that [ __ ]
was still you heard me
shout out to uh kim kardashian yeah
she's the same out of five man she's
like on the mount rushmore of
the spank bank
[Laughter]
yeah let's just make me bro it's like uh
you know if you had to pick like four or
five chicks who you want hits are you
[ __ ] yeah like in your head are you
crazy so be like oh [ __ ] on your spin
kim k j lo
that's all on your [ __ ] yeah nikki
who else
is not bad
vita guerra from like 2003
who's on your spank bank
no names man
no days there's chicks from north philly
that you personally know hell no i'm off
the north philly chicks
no you don't got one check that like you
just grew up like man if i could ever
get the chance i'm fine yeah i did
something with him already
so rihanna you wouldn't want to [ __ ]
rihanna is that what you're telling me
oh wait
rihanna's in a relationship with him
we got to be respectful
he can't be burning my bridges already
i'm just there
we got to be respected
at least there's somebody singing like
sweetie
label mate
we'll do a song together
oh you could do the murder beats anita
thing they're label mates i'm not sure
how real that relationship is you know
i'm gonna hum all of them yeah
yeah that you you say you won't you
don't have to hump all of them no damn
shout out to the hump man i ain't heard
that one
get humpty